الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد او الصامت كما
بات يعرف يبدو انه قد بدا بالفعل وفق ما
نقلت صحيفه واشنطن بوست عن مسؤولين
عسكريين اوكرانيين وعلى ما يبدو ان ملامح
الهجوم المضاد بدات تتكشف حيث اشار
المسؤولون الى ان الهجمات كثفت في مناطق
بجنوب شرقي البلاد
وبحسب الصحيفه فان الهدف الرئيسي هو قطع
طريق البري الرئيسي بين شبه جزيره القرم
وجنوب روسيا اهم طرق الامدادات الروسيه
والجبهه الاكثر ترجيحا ستكون في زبروجيا
وهي الجبهه التي شهدت الساعات الماضيه
هجوما للقوات الاوكرانيه على القوات
الروسيه
وبحسب وزير الدفاع الروسي فان الهجوم نفذه
اللواء سبعه واربعون اوكراني وهو كلمه
السر في الهجوم المضاد المنتظر
اللواء يبلغ تعداده 1500 جندي و150 مدرعه
تلقى تدريبات لاشهر في قاعده للنيتو
بالمانيا
اكتسب خبره ومهارات في تكتيكات النيتو
الحربيه الاكثر تقدما وهو مسلح باسلحه
ومعدات وتقنيات غربيه
قياده اللواء تدربت على اجهزتك كمبيوتر
تحاكي المواقف التي قد يواجهونها في
المعارك الواقعيه ودرسوا نتائج المحاكاه
وبحسب واشنطن بوست فان اللواء سبعه
واربعين نقل الى موقع سري اقرب الى خط
الجبهه بعد تسليح وتدريب للقتال مثل
الجيوش الغربيه لكن بمفردهم ذاك اختبار
للاستراتيجيه التي تقودها الولايات
المتحده تقول موسكو على لسان وزير الدفاع
ان هذه القوه المدربه خصيصا لتحقيق اختراق
فشلت بمهمتها والحقت بها خسائر كبيره
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوث
ائقيات الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات